ennio morricone et ce sont des mélodies
inoubliables comme celle d'il était une
fois dans l'ouest avec morricone et un
film moyen devenait un bon film un bon
film devenait un film excellent et un
très bon film devenu une légende
c'est dire à quel point ils savaient
ajouter de la valeur grâce à sa musique
son nom reste indissociable de celui de
sergio leone et grâce à qui il accède à
la célébrité en 1964 avec le film pour
le poignet de dollars va avoir comme
ceux quelques collaborations assez
durable à la mort de leoni avait
commencé à travailler avec tornato
rissanen cinéma paradiso c'est
magnifique
[Musique]
puis leur a aussi une carrière française
impressionnante
par exemple si film avec henri verneuil
du film de belmondo delon la cage aux
folles des tas de films donc du côté
français prend une autre vie que je n'y
arriverai jamais jeunes aujourd'hui
à côté de ça une carrière américaine qui
mènera un oscar à la toute fin de sa vie
puisqu'il fera la musique de tarantino
qui avait déjà puisé dans sa musique
mais la musique originale débit de
salopards est ce lui vaudra un oscar
bien après son oscar d'honneur
prolifique au cours de sa longue
carrière morricone et à créer plus de
500 musiques de films pour le cinéma en
plus dirigé des orchestres sur scène et
de donner des classes de maître à
laquelle martin léon a eu l'occasion de
participer
[Musique]
du chaud estime beaucoup attristé le
compositeur des musiques de film doit
mettre son ego de côté bien être au
service du film tient il nous dit aussi
votre antre première idée est la bonne
7,6 et celles qui vont vous amener l'eau
vous avez besoin d'aller ennio morricone
et était il restera un monument de la
musique et du cinéma ici n'est bien
alexandre charti radio canada montréal